what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right let me tell you guys something
like every single human being born in
the face of the planet I was born
knowing who Batman is
right it wasn't until comics explain
took off and I started getting into his
character with Scott Snyder's Batman
then I was like okay so Batman is really
cool the way Snyder right so like I love
Snyder's run so I started going through
and looking at old Batman stories not to
sound arrogant but I'd like to believe I
know almost everything there is to know
about Batman like I've read the old
Dennis O'Neil Neal Adams run I read The
Dark Knight Returns I read Batman year
one I read tales of the Dark Knight I've
read all kinds of Batman stories the
whole of Scott Snyder's new videos you
run and Batman eternal let me tell you
something man Batman cold days by Tom
King is some of the best Batman runs
like Batman running I've ever heard of
Jesus it's good man like I even tweeted
out to him I was like Tom King it's some
of the best Batman writing I ever heard
of in my life that just all there is to
it okay so this comes as the aftermath -
Catwoman leaving Batman because Tom King
almost kind of takes like the aftermath
to the death of Jason Todd those you
guys who don't know um when Jason Todd
died following the events of death of
the death and the family like DC was
working towards bringing in like Tim
Drake bring in like a new Robin and so
the idea was that Batman they become
like super dark and like like
ridiculously almost uncontrollable just
kind of maniacal in terms of like how he
would function and how brutal he would
be and this led to Tim Drake who
witnessed the whole thing he was
witnessing like how dark mountain was it
was becoming Tim Drake goes to Dick
Grayson says hey you have to have to go
back to being Robin Tim Drake says no
I'm Nightwing now he says but you should
be Robin instead because Tim Drake had
figured out the identities of Bruce
Wayne and Batman and Tim Drake Stan's
was Batman needs a Robin because he's
almost lost his mind he's just so so
vicious at this point Tom King Conant
takes that and then like reworks it in a
beautiful way and it's it's it's
incredibly there's amazing lines here so
this picks up with Batman getting jury
duty right like like Batman basically
arrives at like Gotham courthouse
because use there for a jury duty but
this is kind of inner spliced in with
moments where like he's it's hacking
Victor freeze and we don't really know
why yet it's kind of cool because Tom
King plays on that he's like what was
your run-of-the-mill thing you know it's
Batman fighting Victor freeze what
happens but it's also something that's
kind of interesting too because the way
the Tom King rights is just like
Batman's never like Bruce Wayne's never
served on jury duty so it's kind of like
a big to-do and in reality it actually
makes sense
they're like somewhere along the line
Bruce Wayne would get jury duty the idea
here is that you know at least as far as
the facts are given uh
the potential jurors because at this
point right now is more or less just
like figuring out for the guys you don't
know how jury duty a jury selection
works what will happen is the
prosecution and the defense will
basically go through and start asking a
series of questions at least for
high-profile jury a jury selection
they'll start asking a series of
questions and they'll analyze the
responses of the jurors to fajn to
basically find jurors that will give
them the best verdict possible and it's
a balancing act right like the
prosecution wants jurors that will find
them find the party guilty and the
defense wants tears that will find the
find the other person innocent so you
kind of have to like go to this
balancing act and they want jurors they
can persuade either way and it's
interesting because Bruce Wayne kind of
puts off this really really impartial
perception of just like yeah like I'm
here but I don't really want to be here
but it's kind of cool because you have
the defense of the prosecution who are
analyzing you know how they react and
what they say they say okay defense does
not object to juror number four
prosecution does not have ejected juror
number four Bruce Wayne selected now
what this means is that he's sequestered
basically meaning they'll be kept in
isolation they'll be put to a hotel
somewhere it'll be a very very secure
hotel no one will know that they're
there I mean they may even be given like
false names in order to keep their
identities hidden that was a big to-do
during like the OJ Simpson case and
things like that the jury were
sequestered so they couldn't be
accessing couldn't be you know coerced
or bribed into finding OJ Simpson guilty
or not guilty or what-have-you but when
Bruce Wayne gets in here and he sits
down and and just sort of starts starts
thinking the one big question we have
here is if he's sequestered for the next
few days meaning he cannot leave the
hotel and he cannot be Batman who's
gonna be Batman in his stead and right
off the bat Tom King answers the
question and says Dick Grayson and it's
beautiful because as soon as this
happened it means okay so like Batman's
not gonna be the forefront of the story
so so the prosecution sits down you
everybody makes her case prosecution
sits down and says you've heard you know
everything that's me I'm sorry the the
defense sits down you know the
prosecution presents their case so they
say hey look here's what happened so on
and so forth and Tom King kind of skips
over right he treats it like an episode
of like Law & Order you know where you
don't see everything that goes on you
just get the highlights of the case and
so the defense is Stannis says here's
where we stand right now you've heard
what the prosecution presented three
women were killed and these three women
were killed by me is that were initially
unknown to the Gotham City Police
Department that it was just kind of like
okay they died of natural causes of
blood clots but then now Batman comes
along and Batman starts poking around
and does what Batman does and figures
out that basically the the cause of
death was brought on by like cold you
know that basically these blood clots
were created by cold it's so in response
it seems as though somehow Batman
figured out what the Gotham City police
probably couldn't figure out now that's
throwing him doubt initially there was
no evidence to show that Victor fries
had killed these women and so now like
then suddenly Batman comes along and
there is evidence so is it true or is it
not true and something of course they
put Commissioner Gordon on the stand and
Commissioner Gordon you know that it
kind of goes like that hard cord
examination where it's like yes or no
answers have those you guys who don't
know in the legal profession it's a way
to basically keep the jury from being
confused and to only stick to the facts
now sometimes what will happen is
lawyers will ask a question in such a
way to where they kind of lean towards
one direction and in this instance it's
basically the the you know the defense
lawyer saying well give me like the one
down here so initially you guys found no
evidence that Victor fries had killed
these girls right the evidence you found
so that there were blood clots yes or no
the answer is yes okay at this point
Batman comes in and Batman starts
examining the body yes or no yes is
Batman licensed to perform autopsies for
the city of Gotham and then that's what
Commissioner Gordon starts to kind of
say hey but look man it's not it's not
so black and white and it is in black
and white but the fact is the lawyers
looking for yes or no answers that's the
way the legal profession works and so
the answer is definitively no Batman is
not licensed to conduct autopsies for
the city of Gotham that throws the
evidence that Batman brought into
question if a person shows up to you and
tells you they're a cop but they're not
does it mean they're a cop and so like
that's that's it's really a cool little
scenario here now of course at this
point you have like the jurors we're
really kind of having like their own
individual discussion they're having
lunch they're kind of talking about
things but they're not taking the case
seriously and right off the bat
Bruce Wayne sort of begins to kind of
snap of course he excuses himself goes
to the bathroom and then freaks out
because what Bruce Wayne has realized in
the blink of an eye and the time they've
been having lunch is that Victor fries
will be found guilty because in this
scenario they see Batman is beyond
reproach
and that's something that he really
focuses on here now of course at that
point we go to detective Bullock
right like Bullock you know of course
you know lieutenant Bullock it's kind of
like hey look uh defense lawyer asked
like the body was dropped off at Gotham
police station yes okay do you know who
put it there well there was no sign that
there was no signature from Batman
saying that he put it there but the guy
had a Batarang in the side of his head
we knew who it was that did it and so
did we go into probably the most damning
piece of evidence here when Victor fries
gets up on the stand and then basically
talked about how he made a confession
but he says I did this because I was so
terrified for my life because he just
kept hitting me over and over and over
again and I didn't know what else to do
and so like I just did what
one and so then you go into the actual
you going to the jury section you know
whether literally like okay you know
we're basically trying to figure out if
he's gonna be guilty or not and you have
all these jurors who are just like well
me just Batman Batman saved Gotham City
he saved me he fights the bad guys he
fights a good fight he's Batman so like
of course Victor freeze was guilty he's
a bad guy and so what ends up happening
is when the questions asked okay does
everybody find Victor freeze guilty
everybody raises their hand except for
Bruce Wayne and Bruce Wayne says I don't
think he's guilty and it's just like
damn so like that's when the plot
thickens and so from there you start
getting it like these super incredible
like explanations like these these
really really amazing scenarios where
like batman starts talking with these
various people and like the jury though
the various jurors are getting up when
they're saying things like hey look like
he's Victor freeze the guy's a
well-known criminal Batman's foam on a
multitude of occasions the guy is he he
does this thing over and over and over
again it's the thing he always does like
he's just a bad guy of course but of
course he was guilty why would Batman be
tracking him down and the response of
Bruce Wayne is that's not reason enough
that's not enough evidence here just
because Batman was chasing a guy does
not mean that guy's guilty there's a
kind of pattern that's going on with
this jury and so Bruce Wayne's test and
says look all I ask is an hour or two
that's all I ask
when this hour or two is done if I
haven't persuaded you I'll find him
guilty but listen to what I have to say
listen to this explanation that I offer
here and so is it's kind of cool because
as he goes through and starts talking to
them and one of these he says he says
like let's let's sit down and let's
start looking at this evidence right so
Commissioner Gordon and the Gotham City
Police Department at the coroner which
by his own admission Commissioner Gordon
said was one of the best coroner's sat
down and found no evidence that there
was any indication these girls had died
by the actions of mr. freeze which is to
say cold was not used to induce these
blood clots and so between the time that
cornered initially did his autopsy and
the time Batman showed up it's possible
someone went in there there's there's no
evidence here to show that no one was in
there and so if there's no evidence to
show no one was in there then that means
you can believe someone was in there
because there's no evidence to show
either way so each each possibility is
entirely possible and so them from there
the question that Bruce Wayne asks is if
Commissioner Gordon the coroner's didn't
find anything and then Batman did then
why why was that the case and one of the
jurors response is because he's Batman
and Bruce Wayne's response is yeah okay
that's not an argument here this is so
cool it's
Bruce Wayne putting himself on trial
right because like looking at looking at
these looking at all these jurors Bruce
Wayne makes this amazing point and he
says so what you're telling me here is
that Commissioner Gordon the coroner
found no evidence that Victor freeze was
involved in this Batman did and you're
gonna convict on that because Batman's
just better that's it that's all the
evidence you need well in that case like
everyone that Batman tracks down is
guilty and it's just like it's like
you're finding somebody guilty based
explicitly on the fact that Batman says
he is and that's what's so awesome about
that because then he in turn says okay
he'll ask the question well then why was
he wearing his suit like why was he
wearing the the you know the whole
Victor freeze costume even though he was
explicitly told not to he was on house
arrest and in part of his probation was
that he could not access his gun or
Zoras or suit and someone had told him
by his own admission someone had told
Victor freeze
Batman's coming for you why would he in
turn completely get dressed up and then
Bruce goes on like this this really
really cool explanation he says for
years and years and years and years
Victor fries and Batman have fought
every single time Victor fries did
something bad Batman will basically come
flying in guns blazing and just beat the
hell out of Victor freeze no questions
would be asked until the end when the
beating was taken and so if you're
Victor fries and someone tells you
Batman's coming for you what in the hell
else are you gonna do besides get your
gun and get your suit you're gonna panic
and you're gonna prep yourself for a
battle because all you've known and your
encounters with Batman is that he would
beat the crap out of you and it's so
cool and so at that point he goes into
the confession which is really the most
damning piece of evidence that Victor
free sat down and he made a confession
to Batman I'm the one who did it I
killed these women so on and so forth
and so from there like Wonder Woman
Missy basically speaks up and says well
I know where you're gonna go you know
and everything
and Batman kind of countered you know
Bruce Wayne counters is no no no no it's
not necessarily like that and then he
goes on a story about himself and that's
what's so cool here he talks about his
life as a child and he says that when he
was a kid when his parents died that all
he knew at that moment in time was just
fear and he would have given anything to
make that stop referring to Batman
indirectly you know of course not
referring not saying like I am Batman
guys it's just kind of like I've had
times in my life when I've had the
highest highs and I've had the lowest
lows but when I'm at my lowest I'll do
anything to make that go away I'll do
anything to bring myself back up to a
happier place
if Victor fries is anything like that if
he's anything like a human being
he's the
exact same way and so in that moment
when Batman is pummeling the hell out of
him he'll say whatever he needs to say
in order to make it stop now the fact
that this is included in here is not an
accident Tom King if you ever see this
video I apologize if I'm stepping on
toast but Tom King used to be a guy who
worked in the CIA and the idea is is one
of the big things I don't how many of
you guys remember back but like post
9/11 in the in the the later years of
the Bush administration one of the
things that people began to learn about
was extraordinary renditions taking
people who were suspected to be
terrorists flying them overseas to
places where torture could be practiced
and then torturing them and then getting
information out of them and on one side
you had people who said no that's
perfectly okay and then on the other
side of the field you had people who
said but torture doesn't work though
people will do whatever that they'll say
whatever they need to say to make the
torture stop the counter-argument to
that is yeah but if they're lying
we'll just torture them again and we'll
keep doing that until they tell the
truth it was just kind of back and forth
but that's why it's thrown in here it's
not an accident and so in turn you know
you have Bruce Wayne who speaks to misy
directly it says hey I noticed you have
a cross you know and she says yeah I
mean I have a cross you know I believe
in God I have faith you know I have all
these things do you believe in God and
Batman's responses I used to Bruce Wayne
says I used to believe in God my father
Thomas Wayne he believed in God he
believed in in in like the hallowed
spirit and the immortal soul and God and
the Trinity and the whole nine yards but
then he says after the death of my
father
I stopped believing I stopped believing
that God was real because where was God
when my mother and father died and and
and that's so cool it's that's so cool
to give us like this introspection of
Bruce Wayne why he doesn't believe in
God everyone who's ever been in like a
terrible situation who's lost someone
close to them and their faith is
questioned it always comes down to that
question well where the hell was God
when my parents died where was God when
my children died what has God done for
like the last two thousand years besides
sit on high and judge people it's it's
all these these really really great
questions that kind of come in and Tom
Keith throws them in there and says
Bruce Wayne has asked them all and so in
turn he kind of tells this story about
himself and says in my lack of belief in
God I turn to something else I knew
there had to be something else out there
to believe in something that was
tangible and what he's doing here
without telling them is telling them the
journey on how he became Batman and he
kind of goes on and he says like we're
all here because like were citizens of
this city we're all here because we're
citizens of Gotham
and if we're citizens of Gotham we know
what Gotham is about we know they Gotham
sucks
we know that Gotham can be a crappy
place the Gotham cos is home to just
some of the worst scum in the world but
there he is the man in the cape saving
and saving us all fighting the bad guys
to feeding the villains he's everything
that we could hope him to be what he
does is he he kind of paints his picture
and he says or at least the question is
asked you know do you believe do you
believe Batman's got at least questions
asked to Bruce Wayne for Missy she says
Batman makes mistakes but you believe
Batman might be God and his response is
actually pretty ironic he says I thought
he was a god like I believed he was a
God at some point in time and then he
asked a question how many of you are
here because of Batman and and of course
they all raised their hands like yeah
we've been saved by Batman at some point
in time and he says that's the problem
that's the problem here if you truly
believe like like if you believe that
mr. Freeze's is innocent then that means
that you have to believe that Batman
screwed up and if you believe that
Batman screwed up
then suddenly Batman's not God anymore
then Batman's not infallible as far as
you're concerned
Batman you know God is above us and he
wears a cape and when I was reading
through this and I saw that I was just
like God in heaven man this guy has a
way with words
it's funny because he says like you have
to believe the Batman Scott you are here
because Batman saved you and you feel
like maybe you owe something or because
of the greatness of Batman that he's an
infallible person the way that you would
expect God to save you if Batman saved
you instead and therefore Batman takes
the place of God in your lives he's the
world's greatest detective he's a guy
that never screwed up he's just he's
just that good we trust that Batman will
always make the right decision and if he
makes a wrong decision did it means that
he aired it means we can't necessarily
trust him anymore and it's so cool
because he calls people's perception of
Batman into question it says you know is
he's like it's like the story of Joe and
it's so cool he brings up he says it's
like the story of Joe that Joe has his
whole life ripped apart by God in a
gamble between God and the devil and
when when Joe questions and says why are
you doing this to me God's response is
I'm the man who made like the mountains
and miracles who are you to question me
let's how people perceive Batman the
people in Gotham City they look at him
they say he's he's I mean look at him
he's up there we worship at the altar of
Batman in the form of praising his
greatness you know and never calling him
into question but the response is he's a
man just like everybody else he screws
up and he makes mistakes and he does
dumb things he's not some infallible
being he's just a man nothing more than
that
and so it's it's it's crazy here because
then he sort of
to kind of move in this direction of
talking about the the life that he had
with Selena Kyle what he tells us is
that for the longest time in his life
all he's ever really known is misery and
sadness that he lost the greatest thing
he ever had in the form of his parents
and then he turned a Batman in order to
try to find happiness but never found it
all we found was violence and all he
found was more violence and that was it
violence sadness and loss and then when
he'd almost given up he found happiness
he found happiness in the form of Selina
Kyle the one thing he never thought he
would ever be able to find he found
happiness and he found love and then it
was yanked away from him she took off
and he was right back where he was
before
it's Bruce Wayne saying like I am at the
lowest point of my life right now I am
as low as my life has been since the
death of my parents is almost Batman
like Bruce Wayne pleading with himself
and then pleading with them to like to
understand the nature of Batman that he
screws up that he makes mistake cities
that he's not an infallible being and so
if they believe that Batman is truly a
man if they believe that Batman is truly
a guy that he's not some God up there
listening that they have to accept that
he screws up and if they have to accept
that he screws up then they have to
remove Batman from the equation of all
the evidence here at the courtroom and
they have to say look at the facts for
what they are noting here supports that
Victor fries killed these girls and so
you have to find him not guilty and
making this like compelling argument and
one of the greatest Batman stories ever
told in turn the jury finds him not
guilty now it doesn't mean the Batman's
walk walking away it doesn't mean he's
just letting him go it's just like we're
gonna go on the trail of figuring out
who's actually at large here not only
that Kane throws in a couple things what
would that answer would be without a
couple of a couple of funny moments what
we end up finding out here is that Bruce
Wayne never really believed that Victor
fries was guilty but he had pummeled the
hell out of him he'd beat the hell out
of him and thrown him on the doorstep of
the Gotham City Police Department
because he snapped because he lost
control of himself and in losing control
all he wanted to do was just make Victor
fries suffer because Victor fries happen
to be the one who was there and so in
that moment because of the fact that he
knew he screwed up he bribed his way
onto the jury he bribed his away in the
jury duty in order to convince the
jurors not to find Victor fries guilty
and have him executed because his life
was on the line and so so in turn he
basically contacts al furnaces Alfred
I'm totally lost
after losing Selina Kyle I'm lost I have
to regain my bearings I have to regain
my roots and he goes back to the old
school costume goes back to the og
costume that all of us know and love
Batman's kind of starting over again and
trying to refine himself what this means
it's anybody's guess but I am sure as
hell excited to find out with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
let's explain make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you